in the opening scene we are introduced
to an oppressive dystopian world that is
controlled by a so-called State their
strict rules dominate every aspect of
life and they are known to manipulate
Minds creativity and Innovations are
replaced by excessive loyalty towards
the state's belief the scene then shifts
to a woman named Janet Tyler who seems
to have been kidnapped and brought to
this world she is from another planet
where oppression doesn't exist it turns
out that she has just undergone her 11th
treatment procedure in hopes of fixing
her facial deformity the state wants her
to look normal like the other people
residing here with her original
appearance she will be hated and
rejected by Society currently confined
within a hospital room Janet's head is
completely covered by bandages obscuring
her face entirely from vo the doctors
and nurses who are lurking in the
shadows of the darkened hospital room
describe her face as a pitiable
distorted mass of Flesh indicating that
she is very ugly however the ultimate
outcome of the treatment procedure will
remain a mystery until until the
bandages are removed Janet who is
overwhelmed by the unbearable presence
of the bandages on her face pleads with
the doctor she tries her best to
convince him to remove the burdensome
coverings ahead of schedule however the
doctor remains cautious and unsure
expressing doubts about the chances of
things turning out well in an attempt to
comfort her he informs her that there
are many others who share the same
Misfortune in fact some people look much
worse than she does he goes on to say
that if the current treatment proves
unsuccessful the state would permit her
to meet other people of her kind so that
they can form a community and feel
better about themselves but this idea
only worries Janet even more as she
dislikes living amongst such people
striving to convince the doctor of her
desire to exist as a normal human being
Janet proposes the use of masks in order
to hide her face she even promises that
she will never bother anyone or even go
near them to support a living she will
accept any job she can get whether it be
small or big however despite all of her
claims the doctor reminds her that
social policies are determined by the
state and his actions are bound by the
regulations established therein Janet
who has now become angry protests
vehemently against the Injustice of the
system according to her the state
neither possesses Divine Authority nor
the capacity to dictate the course of
human lives so it cannot just punish
people for being born with deformities
as Janet's efforts to sway the doctor
prove futile her frustration escalates
driving her to a state of frenzy she
screams at the top of her lungs to have
the bandages removed from her face
immediately however the doctrine nurse
somehow managed to hold her and
administer a dose of sedative making her
fall into a deep sleep after some time
has passed the doctor eventually decides
to remove the layers of bandages around
Janet's face he then instructs his
co-workers to make the necessary
arrangements for the same however amidst
the preparations a nurse hesitates to
carry out the orders as she is
uncomfortable with how Janet looks when
the doctor learns of this he becomes
visibly upset and questioned is why
Janet or anyone else should be judged
solely based on how they look from the
outside he actually feels bad for the
patients and wants everyone to treat
them as normal human beings however the
nurse simply tells him to refrain from
questioning her any further as it is
considered treason hearing this the
doctor finds himself in a very difficult
situation he really wants to support
Janet and help her feel better but at
the same time he has to abide by the
strict regulations made by the state in
the next scene we are introduced to a
prominent figure in the ruling hierarchy
of the state who takes center stage on
National Television to talk about the
virtues of a glorious Conformity the
leader reminisces about a previous era
of humanity that was viewed as lacking
Direction lacking productivity and
excessively driven by sentimental
emotions during that time people held a
strange idea that differences among
individuals didn't matter much they
didn't discriminate when it came to race
color cast religion and more importantly
facial features however the leader
confidently asserts that these beliefs
have now been proved wrong there are
scientific facts which prove that a
person is superior if he or she has
better facial features this is why
Canada has had a prime minister for
eight years who enjoys going bananas on
Halloween back at the hospital the
doctors come to a conclusion he is now
about to remove Janet's bandages freeing
her of All the Troubles she has endured
but prior to starting this critical
procedure he issues a Stern warning
asking her to remain still the doctor
stresses that if she makes even a slight
movement he will make the nurses hold
her back and administer her with
anesthesia inducing a state of sedation
hearing this Janet is a bit scared but
she responds with a calm voice that she
will be at her best behavior she will
also refrain from being emotional or
crying but this understanding
established the doctor commences the
delicate process of unraveling the
bandages the atmosphere in the room is
tense as they have spent weeks on the
surgery Janet also starts becoming
nervous but the doctor quickly calms her
down and offers her Comfort he assures
her that even if the ultimate outcome of
this this procedure falls short of
expectations she will still have the
opportunity to lead a long and
fulfilling life she can live within a
community of people who share her
similar circumstances in that Community
people don't discriminate at all instead
they help each other out it is almost
like the early ages where everyone was
equal except now they're all poor too
hearing all of this Janet becomes
concerned and inquires if there are any
alternative options in case of the
procedure failure in response the doctor
discloses that under specific
circumstances the state permits the
extermination of certain individuals
deemed undesirable however he
acknowledges the presence of multiple
factors to be taken into account
including Janet's age and overall
physical condition since she is healthy
and young it is almost certain that she
won't be exterminated after much
anticipation the moment arrives when the
last layer of the bandage is finally
lifted everyone watches with nervousness
hoping that the procedure has worked
however their expression quickly changes
when they catch a glimpse of her face
sadly Janet Still Remains the Same ugly
and undesirable even after all these
procedures she cannot change what she
has become following this we are finally
shown Janet's face which contrary to our
expectations is strikingly beautiful she
has a mesmerizing appearance like that
of an actress or a model in our familiar
World however in a shocking turn of
events the camera then pans to the
doctors nurses and other staff and we
get to know that their faces are
completely deformed and twisted their
faces appear droopy with heavy brows
tired and lifeless eyes swollen and
twisted lips and wrinkled noses with
noticeably larger nostrils reminiscent
of pig snouts with this revelation we
finally get to know the nature of the
place having deformed facial features is
considered normal and desirable while
the people with beautiful faces are
hated and despised they are given less
rights are made fun of by the locals and
are forbidden from dating the desirable
ones in short they are subjected to
excessive hate and treated like trash
meanwhile when Janet notices the faces
of the hospital staff she freaks out and
starts screaming all this time she was
under the impression that the people
here would be better looking but it is
actually the exact opposite Dr oink oink
and the piggledy wiggledies try to calm
her down saying everything is fine but
she pushes them aside and escapes the
room but as Janet navigates through the
hospital's hallways she begins to
witness the startling Revelations of
what is deemed normal within this
alternate reality everywhere she turns
she is confronted by the sight of people
whose appearances are very different
from the conventional standards of
beauty that she had known meanwhile the
hospital's flat screen televisions which
are present throughout the premises
suddenly announce the presence of the
state's leader in his speech the leader
announces about the virtues of
Conformity urging the citizens to live
unitedly with the people of the same
kind he appears to be a hateful person
who despises humans from other worlds on
the other hand Janet reaches a room
where she comes across a handsome
individual by our standards he goes by
the name Walter Smith just then the
doctor also arrives and delivers some
encouraging news he reveals that Walter
is one of the inhabitants from the
deformed Community where Janet is
destined to end up this community is
composed entirely of people who share
her physical characteristics a place
where her perceived ugliness will not be
a source of concern for the state Janet
is overwhelmed by the information and
she does not know how to react sensing
her nervousness and doubt Walter
approaches her and offers her Comfort he
explains that she will surely find a
love and belonging in the community and
also assures her that she will live a
happy life there moreover he shares a
saying passed down through the ages that
beauty lies in the eyes of the beholder
which means that while people of the
state and their society May deem Janet's
appearances unattractive there exists
other people in The Wider world who will
perceive her innate Beauty following
this emotional exchange Janet and Walter
start their Journey towards their
separate Community side by side at this
point our protagonist has finally found
a sense of comfort and she is very
excited to meet other people just like
her she wants to do normal things which
are impossible under the governance of
the state like going out for shopping
eating at restaurants partying at clubs
making new friends and so on but now
with this community her dreams will
finally come true the movie ends as the
medical staff observes the couple's
departure from afar
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching